you
all right this is starting any second
now this is the Murray tournament a king
of the hill tournament get your king to
any one of the four center squares and
it is if it is as if you just gave
checkmate to your opponent I don't care
about that
I'm alright with this take there I want
to get to e4 with my king
like right now let's secure this d3
Square first stop them from castling and
take are you gonna take
get out of there King I give this check
hmm
what a move man oh man
the Queen takes d3 oh man what a shot ah
okay whoa all right all right I see I
see I see I see
whoa all righty
get up King get up King I can also win
by regular means right it seems like
it's close to checkmate oh he's running
away
let's go here go there Nate soon you
know I could just go for regular stuff
well said
he's going for regular stuff is he he's
going for regular stuff
Oh makes sense no he's just going for
regular stuff you know what's that move
about no idea enough six grab this guy
okay lean trade here and then I get to
this square next I get to this square
next free move oh okay they I have this
square covered
there's no ruck here primo primo vacha
king king of the hill er ah man it's
still stunned by that first game Queen
takes d3o okay let's go with what here
I'm afraid to preserve all right maybe
just play regular right if they go crazy
towards the center with their King it's
maybe too much all right they're gonna
throw it up Bishop check a knight here
might be good fine with this oh it's the
F pawn move mmm
I should be going with an F pawn advance
the birds opening is white and then King
F - that's right opposite the king
alright I feel like I need to castle
want to get rid of that night mmm let's
go after their king dislodge the nine
throw my knight on e4 how about that
pawn takes I take the knight and then
take on e5 now let's kick the night I
should be winning that pawn now
after their king let's just recap sure
right away
and let's take a ship here let's go here
I don't want the king to sneak out I'm
with my bishop on c3 and then we'll look
for mates
I got a mate lined up here soon
rook to be one ideas Queen to the B file
setting it up now mate in three four
something close to that and I got the
rook cleaning block if the Queen they
also don't have any time I shouldn't
have done that
let's keep the Queen around back to
tournament whoo okay
f4 that's what I should be doing f4f
we're not here and then king of - I like
this idea sneaky
all right I want to do this let's take
get rid of their night give it check
also it's gonna step up here can you
have six I could get that pawn Fischer
takes Knight I take with the King making
one threat night here doesn't work got
to have five the knight is pinned that's
me
I determined that's me that's king of
the hill
twelve twelve eight six plenty of time
left
f4 mm-hmm
you agree with this idea f4 9 f3 king f2
is
to do this against a computer probably
mm-hmm Knight c3 no that's so fast and
they're not moving
let's get my knight in here okay I got
their Queen I do have to be careful
though
well it might be a full queen unless the
King goes all the way back
Oh getting a rook as well my knight is
extra excited however you know I'm too
afraid of this and then the Kings
sneaking in let's do that
and then kick that King back I already
moved come here there push I want to get
that King back okay no I'm gonna step up
with my King Mahin to threat okay there
we go
King d4 remove that defender of d4 back
to term in 12 12 12 10 less than 23
minutes in this one we have who many
more have entered since the start 49 50
Collett 50 players in this one maybe
regular chess with this so having an
extra pawn in the center I think is good
and you know what yeah when pawns are
fixed it's much more difficult for there
to be like a quick King race towards the
center so push up here okay let's break
down their center oh this this stuff
who I don't want to allow this pawn to
take and then King up here king f7 okay
I just I just said earlier they want
them to take then they have that square
what am i doing now I'm allowing that
very thing okay hmm their night he's too
strong
he's way too strong okay
oh I missed that man hmm what am i doing
they have past problems over here do you
realize that they have passed pawns oh
man
and my king is cut off 11 seconds also
is not very much sneak my king up you
only a moment away mates friend finally
back to tournament dog Lee gave those
funds were so dangerous those a and B
pawns they were ready to bring the pain
16s this is the pack leader
you know what the Cairo the advance
Cairo alright
you gonna cancel yeah you did council I
like seeing that
give me the H file which piece that one
wow they are living dangerous dangerous
um I think I got to do that and drop
upon yeah let's look I have to do f5
it's important I drop upon in their
position these are too much fun let's go
into a pin no I didn't want to do that I
really didn't
gonna push now take run over here oh boy
let's take with the King they're gonna
move oh no oh boy I'm actually pretty
close with my King much closer than they
are they
the Queen's off I'm happy with that my
Kings really close he might be worth a
piece it's running to me got it back to
tournament they forgot they were in a
regular chess mode twenty twenty
nineteen seventeen and that was big we
were tied no actually I was behind a
little bit but now we're tied but I'm on
streak he's not all right the bird is
the word here let's get this duo in and
maybe hold off with such a quick King f2
I haven't ruled it out alright you know
what another thing is I could just
castle and I still have a fast track
towards the center without my F pawn
here that's maybe way to play it could
do one of these you know you know well
let's get out of checks don't tricky
stuff against my unprotected bishop now
just defend there
Knight to e2 c3 exploit the pin okay I
also went away from the center with this
King move let's get back over here let's
get back over get this rook working
let's take Queen takes I push and then
push again I've been on any time where's
the night going grab this pawn let's see
what they do here let's take care stop
there King oh I live in dangerous
they're living dangerous factor
tournament 24 24 22 who John Madden is
in first there I guess on tiebreaks not
quite at the halfway point 17 Collett 17
minutes 24 24 22 we will get paired up I
imagine okay let's go d5 oh that's an
interesting move efore there I want to
maintain my knight there so let's take
like that mmm chip away at their
furthest advanced pawn this
let's take their develop the Queen
develop my knight to c6 keep pressure on
their center and King to f7 I'm not
gonna Castle here King f7 rook to e8
because I could take here can you have
six soon let's take I'm on their queen
they could take care with check missed
that okay rook here
Queen check maybe yes and king up
threatening me how do you stop that
don't back determined they had to play
Queen e2 or f4 but I would have at least
on Queen e2 they would end up in a pin
after I move my bishop 29 28 26 22
halfway point the hedgehog okay
thinking it throw the hedgehog at me
let's see yeah I like having the F pond
up Bishop g2 council that's maybe too
crazy flush that King back take some
material are they gonna come back with
their King mm-hmm
allow this move to get in there King
really is close maybe I could do this
too ah sneaky tactic Knight takes e4
King III threatens Knight takes e4 take
with the night
yeah his king isn't getting towards the
center Queen here no that's not working
actually it is because the bishop takes
here and then king e4 okay this should
be working now how do you stop my king
from getting to e4 next
that should work
it's game back to tournament thirty-two
thirty twenty nine twenty to twenty he's
the the guy that since okay this is big
oh really
that's tough the Fromm gambit okay let's
pin your knight
let's see how you like it
all right let's get developed threatens
me maybe is it made or not make up your
mind
oh all right let's get rid of that guy
clean checkers maybe there okay yeah I
don't see how no I shouldn't move it
away with my king I gotta get closer
King on g2 oh boy
so much for getting closer okay Queen on
h4 wouldn't be fun
you really wouldn't over here here oh
how we doing on the clock let's get that
move in here I have an idea
it is scary look at our King physicians
rook takes pawn it's so scary let's
check you can't take your pinned let's
come up I want to take here push and
then King you for I got it can't stop
King e4 successfully
oh yeah after this h3 move after the h3
move I could have just taken my king the
h3 move if I went to the corner that was
ever been to stuck okay ah 36 35 29 is
where we are out let's try a Sicilian
the winged gambit okay hmm
no this is maybe too bit too crazy bit
too crazy gonna run up with there
King already gonna undermine that
furthest advanced pawn oh let's just run
wild ooh
invite me forward develop my king okay
yeah that was terrible that was terrible
pawn takes soon oh boy oh boy I'm close
to getting mated I'm real close to
getting mated Wow
yeah and what am I supposed to do Wow
what does that even do nothing the King
just steps up man I resign oh that was
an awful game ah man they just pushed me
right back
that f5 move is strong mm 36 35 32 26
well this is the guy in second can we
just play a regular game of chess maybe
just a regular game or we don't have a
crazy King moves okay I don't want to
castle just yet I maybe it's still a
good idea in regular chess to not castle
III should sack here I should really
sack now we're gonna move the King up
here we go Queen takes Knight King here
is the threat
got it I was important important win
there back to tournament those you know
these tactic these clearance tactics
they're really sneaky and king of the
hill you just get a piece out of the way
so your King could step foot on one the
center squares and do so with uh do so
with check or a capture okay so the
second place guy at least drop back some
he's not on streak that's what I meant
okay
oh maybe Bishop d3 yeah what's wrong
with that okay I could maybe get my King
on f3 that should be a pretty decent
square I want to preserve my knight on
c3 so I'm gonna take huh hmm let's
undermine this pawn a controller over
that center square it's gonna be tough
to really get the King in the center
think here's a fine spot though rook a
g1 now let's go to the center I don't
have any time let's take look here feels
like my kinky like fall for a mate just
a moment here Queen here I could run
away though back determent they're down
on time forty thirty eight thirty to
seven minutes and change looking well
forty thirty eight thirty to thirty one
of us for most likely okay Scandinavian
Wow
it's just like a wind by force with the
Scandinavian is that what we have going
on here no way
get backing - you're being too wild too
wild
there I go am i king equally wild
equally wild take them I want the D
Foursquare not sure what that does not
quite sure what that does get out of
there oh boy let's go here discover
check get further away from the center
please they can win material with this
move
it's another check check pawn push I
have Queen c4 should have a mate let's
check let's check and we have mate next
actually by regular means we have GG by
regular means they're 44 38 35 34 five
minutes left John Madden again alrighty
let's try this
ina alrighty and let's take
clamp down okay now with this space
advantage and it makes something happen
oh yeah it's too much to really run
towards the center that early I'm gonna
still try though King on f7 is good King
on f7 Oh sneaky looking for King here
minute threat somehow and do have four
and you get him out of there uh-huh all
right let's just centralize I guess take
here
that's me back to tournament they forgot
48:38 3034 okay ten point gap four
minutes on the dot
now that already let's try you for d4
and let's try this that's what my
opponent tried let's break up their
Center and now rapid development do c4
just develop don't counsel here and then
takes what's that about
just they miss that and I'm gonna run my
king up I have that you know my queen
could control all the center squares
Queen in the center will do that let me
kick the King back some get my king up
and there we go now we're cookin King
here king d4 cannot be prevented
remove the me back to tournament 5240
3834 less than three alrighty
hmm let's see
suit 22 let's try a Scandinavian take
with the epon okay it's a race towards
the center real quick real quick I don't
mind that guy not really threatening
anything I'm already lost that was
stupid pawn push okay I have to do this
they had push and then I couldn't stop
them from getting to e4 of it eventually
that was that was stupid mm-hmm no why
would I take like that take like this I
get a win they're thinking they're
definitely thinking well it's really
locked up in the center mmm Wow okay
that's important I need to control this
pawn not so much concerned about losing
the exchange and I still good control
actually I'm gonna win now bishop here's
threat you gotta play rook here this
cannot be prevented so on those
clearance a clearance sacrifice 56:41
4037 less than a minute I should still
get paired up once more all right last
game here
mmm Heidi 5hmc six a Slav okay it's
regular chess game now I'm gonna castle
mm-hmm okay with that allows my King to
get all the way up here that's got to be
pretty good now the trick will be to
invest some material gonna clear this
pawn out of the way hmm
let's go here
Queen check Queens off is like close to
losing all right let's not get too fancy
mmm Queen exchange all right
let's back up King back up threatening
mate this should do it now rook to d3
came to d5 next rook takes in the rook
in the corner I take the one on d1 we
got maid happening King to d5 and that's
going to do it back to tournament land
hoof this is always tricky the King the
hell man
5643 4137 final standings here see who
else took part in this one the page one
two three four five six already it's
been a while for a king of the hill
tournament pretty rare but to the 56 of
you that took part in this good games
all
you